- So Margot, is it true
that you had a sleepover
like before the cast,
before the movie?
- We had a Barbie sleepover.
It was as fun as it sounds.
- As it sounds. Yeah. It was--
- It was Greta's idea.
- Yeah, it was Greta's idea.
I can't take credit.
We all went to like Claridge's
which is a really
gorgeous hotel in London.
We all like shared beds
and like wore our pajamas
and ordered room service
and played games and found
out that America is like
exceptionally competitive.
(audience laughs)
- I am extremely competitive
and nobody told me
that it was a sexy Barbie sleepover.
So everybody was in like
really pretty silky nightgowns
and I was in like the most
grandma floral twin set
you could imagine.
- She somehow simultaneously
looked like an old lady,
but a five year old at the same time.
It was the cutest.
And she's so teen.
- While she's yelling at you during day.
- Yeah. While she's screaming at you.
But it was very, it was so charming.
I mean, she was like
these cutest little thing.
You'd put like a toddler in
to go to bed and then she was
like rousing at us for not
knowing the rules. It was--
- If you're not gonna play--
- If you're not gonna
compete, why are you here?
- If you're not gonna do, like why play?